el miedo no es algo que yo desconozco
porque es algo que he vivido
y que sigo viviendo es algo con lo que
tenemos que luchar cada día y por eso
hoy les quiero contar unas cuantas
anécdotas en mi vida yo inicié los
clavados a los 7 años de edad en un club
deportivo en la ciudad de mérida yucatán
de donde soy pero nunca me imaginé los
retos que la vida me tenía preparados a
los 11 años me seleccionan para formar
parte de niños con proyección para ver
si algún día podíamos representar a
méxico en unos juegos olímpicos pero en
ese momento era algo que yo veía muy muy
lejano y les cuento y empiezo esta es tt
con esta historia porque fue el primer
reto que tuve que vencer el dejar a mi
familia en mérida para poderme ir a la
ciudad de mexico y poder cumplir sus
sueños
cuando llegue a méxico hace un frío
tremendo y les digo porque yo siendo de
mérida todavía no tenía mi acreditación
el comité olímpico mexicano y vivía en
uno de las colonias más bravas en ese
tiempo en la ciudad de mexico donde mis
papás tienen los amigos y ahí estaba
pero tiene que despertarme todos los
días a las cuatro y media de la mañana
caminar a esa hora en la ciudad de
mexico
todavía no salía ni el sol para caminar
unas cuadras llegar a la estación del
metro agarrar tres estaciones bajarme en
chapultepec agarrar una micro y poder
llegar a la escuela en salida de la
escuela a la 1 40 de la tarde tenía que
salir corriendo hacia el comité olímpico
que estaba a unas cuadras de por ahí
porque mi entrenamiento empezaba de 2 de
la tarde a 3 55 porque así tan exacto
porque a las 4 cerraban el comedor
entonces tenía solamente cinco minutos
para cambiarme atravesar todo el comité
olímpico mexicano y llegar al comedor
antes de que cerraran porque obviamente
si cerraban como comía
yo era de esos niños que masticaba casi
60 veces el bocado y era bastante
melindroso pero ahí aprendí a comer y
comer rápido porque si no te daban 10
minutos de tolerancia y si no comidas se
te iba el tiempo tenía aproximadamente
una hora para adelantar mi tarea
descansar porque el siguiente
entrenamiento era de 5 a 8 55 porque se
repetía la historia para llegar al
comedor tenía que agarrar todo el
transporte de regreso hasta la casa
terminar mi tarea
y descansar cuando te das cuenta la
energía que tiene un niño y las cosas
que vas viviendo que no te das cuenta no
te das cuenta las cosas que vas que vas
pasando y esto me lleva a recordar a los
ojos de mi madre cuando se despide de mí
en el comité olímpico cuando ya ya ya
había entrado me encargo con todas las
personas desde el director hasta la
persona de aseo le encargó a mi bebé por
favor cuiden me lo que no le pase nada
vigilen lo y uno de los consejos más
grandes que me dio mi mamá fue es tu vas
a estar solo aquí ya no te voy a ver ya
no ya no te voy a vigilar cualquier
decisión que vaya a tomar piensa que te
diríamos para ello si la haces o no la
haces tengo 32 años el día de hoy y la
sigo utilizando créanme gracias a ese
consejo no he metido la pata tan grave
tan grave tan
y aquí van les quedaron los puntos unos
puntos el que me antecedió hablo de algo
así como esto pero es muy importante les
voy a dar estos puntos para vencer el
miedo porque el miedo es algo que no nos
permite alcanzar lo que queremos
alcanzar porque todo el mundo estamos en
la zona de confort porque todo mundo te
dice que no cuando quieres hacer algo
imagínense que yo no hubiera decidido
irme a la ciudad de mexico
no estaría el día de hoy hablando en
frente de ustedes y el primer punto que
les quiero hablar es identifiquen sus
creencias falsas todos los miedos vienen
infundados de algo alguien tiene miedo a
nadar porque de niño lo empujaron o
alguien tiene miedo de empezar una nueva
relación porque su antigua relación fue
desastrosa o tenemos muchísimos miedos
pero hay que identificar el por qué no
me van a querer pero ya los tres años
cuando era bebé me daba miedo el mar no
podía mis papás meterme al mar por eso a
los tres años me escriben a natación
para vencer ese miedo y fue algo que le
agradezco a mis papás porque a los tres
años obviamente no sabes cómo vencer sus
miedos
una de las
historias que me marcó fue entre 3 y 5
años
mis papás tenían que alejarse de la casa
dejarme y me preguntaron que si me
quería quedar nuevamente yo ya te
sientes grande en ese en esa edad no sé
si alguien es de mi edad pero ya me
sentía un power rangers en esa época
entonces dije no hay ningún problema se
van de la casa y al poquito tiempo
me invade el miedo mira perder a mi
familia a mi de estar solo media que no
regresarán me pongo a llorar me acurrucó
hasta que pues me duermo quien diría que
unos años después
ese miedo infundado lo tenía que vencer
tendrá que dejar a mi familia para poder
viajar a la ciudad de méxico- vivir solo
y poder cumplir mis sueños
esos son los retos más grandes que me
han marcado pero también uno de los que
más me ha definido por eso y que
identificar que nos da miedo y vencerlo
el miedo siempre va a estar el segundo
punto que les quiero compartir es que
creemos que construyamos nuestras cosas
a pequeños pasos muchas veces queremos
comernos todo el pastel
te vas a atragantar obviamente tienes
que ir paso a paso identificar qué
quieres qué quieres como lo quieres y
por qué lo quieres muchas veces no lo
tenemos tan identificado pero es
importante cuando tienes una meta tienes
que ponerle número cifra el porqué qué
pasa por ejemplo enclavados el clavo se
desarma tiene tres estructuras la salida
la ejecución y la entrada no llegó en
una competencia digo hoy voy a hacer
siete vueltas tres giros y voy a caer no
lo desarmó lo preparo luego lo uno como
un rompecabezas y lo hago pero para
poder tener tener esto tienes que tener
muy definidas tus metas mi meta ahora
importante es dentro de dos años y la
tengo definida medalla de oro en los
juegos olímpicos de toque 2020 se la
fecha es el día es el donde es el porque
sé cuántos puntos tengo que hacer para
trabajar día con día porque te levantas
muchas veces y estás cansado pero si
tienes muy fijo qué es lo que quieres si
tienes tu lista y basta chando día con
día te va a llegar vas a llegar a
cumplir
y esas pequeñas esos pequeños logros que
va realizando te motivan hacia el otro y
muchas veces no lo vas a alcanzar la
primera adivinen cuántos clavados he
hecho a lo largo de mis 25 años de
carrera deportiva un aproximado
nos va a facilitar dos millones de
clavados
y créanme que sigo fallando en
competencias y en entrenamientos no no
tengo me faltan dedos para contar las
veces que he fallado pero eso no quiere
decir que esté mal cada competencia cada
resultado que voy teniendo me va
motivando hacia la siguiente meta el
tercer punto que les quiero compartir es
que vivan el hoy el ahora
muchas veces nos quedamos en el pasado
en lo que pasó en lo que en lo que nos
trajo el día de hoy o si no estamos en
el que pudiéramos hacer pero no nos
aventamos ese paso
el pasado y es algo que no podemos
cambiar podemos aprender de él
ciertamente porque nos ha convertido a
la persona que somos el día de hoy y el
futuro es algo que es incierto que no
sabemos
el presente por eso se llama así porque
es un regalo y lo tenemos en nuestras
manos y tenemos que hacer todo lo
posible para cumplir nuestras metas les
voy a poner una historia este año es uno
de mis mejores clavados que es tres y
media vueltas y media holandés ya se los
explico salen las vueltas hacia hacia
atrás pero hacia enfrente para que no
caiga hacia arriba del trampolín ok
entendiendo eso tienes que ver cada
vuelta tienes que ver dónde vas a pensar
que es mi mejor clavado me perdí me subí
que en el aire intento en un trauma
porque lo hacía y me pegaba y me pegaba
y a pesar que es agua duele como un
tablazo y lo hacía y lo hacía y ya se te
queda un trauma lo lo pare lo empecé a
desarmar lo empecé a trabajar parte por
parte y en el nacional
mi entrenador decidió que no lo hiciera
para dejarlo para clasificar y después
en la copa del mundo afortunadamente la
estrategia salió bien y clasifiqué voy a
la copa del mundo lo hago antes de ir a
la copa del mundo pero lo hice con un
sistema que es una burbuja hecha aire y
si llegas a caer mal se amortigua el
golpe cuando llegó a la copa del mundo
el primer día de entrenamiento me lo
ponen entonces decido hacer dos clavados
y luego las tres y moland es cuando ya
me subo y lo voy a hacer en mi cabeza
estaba el miedo y lo el pasado de lo que
había hecho de los golpes y también
pensaba y si lo hago voy a caer mal y
está el chino y está la alemana y los
jueces y me van a ver y van a decir que
yo cómo es posible tantos años haciendo
clavados y parece un niño aquí sufriendo
se te meten mucho recuerda la cabeza me
para el trampolín
y no lo hice así
luego lo hice me bajé el icam entrenador
no o sea hoy de verdad no puedo todo el
día sufriendo en el hotel como es
posible usar de reprochándome al otro
día llegué y la actitud de ahí acá y te
da todo o sea yo llegué ya es saber
estoy aquí estoy ahora si no lo hago no
voy a competir independientemente lo que
pase me pare y ya no fue él el estar en
el en el pasado en el futuro estar en
ese momento en lo que tienes que hacer
no hay nada más que lo que tienes que
hacer me paro lo hago subo y caigo bien
ya sé que respiras y muchas veces pronto
en las competencias con estas parado que
piensas
porque está el público la gente la
prensa la medalla si gana sino el
patrocinador en lo que tienes que hacer
no hay nada más importante que ese
momento eso que tienes que hacer no hay
nada más que si dejas de prendido el gas
que si la novia que si nada nadie tienes
que estar ahí en ese momento en lo que
tienes que hacer
otra cosa muy importante es esa actitud
créanme que muchas veces lo han visto en
el deporte no gane el mejor si no gana
el que tenga la mejor actitud
ese día el que se levante con las ganas
de hacerlo hay un ejercicio que yo hago
cada día bueno intento que es levantarte
y decir hoy va a ser el mejor día hoy va
a ser un buen día no importa si te bajas
si te pegas el pie dices ah yo y siempre
se mano me pegues al dedo chiquito me lo
software de la suerte
y así vas día con día y cada cosa que te
pase a jabo y vienes de la suerte y de
la suerte y tú te vas hablando y todo
eso que te vas diciendo así que tu día
sea productivo no porque tu jefe o
lupita en el trabajo llegue si hay otra
vez la voy a ver no al contrario la
lupita cómo estás ya llegas por esto
musiquita la actitud es todo lo que ha
aprendido a lo largo de 25 años de
carrera deportiva es que tienes que
disfrutar las cosas al fin y al cabo las
tienes que hacer tengo que realizar mis
clavados tengo que ir a entrenar tienes
que ir a trabajo tienes que ir a la
escuela pero la actitud que le pongas a
las cosas está depende de ti tú tienes
el poder de cambiar todas las cosas y su
actitud si tú cambias de una manera
positiva vas a llegar tus objetivos
porque una medalla no te hace un campeón
pero ser buena persona compartir y
lograr tus metas eso sí te es un campeón
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]